we're going to start with breaking news
from burkina faso where the army has
seized control of the country within the
past half hour a group of soldiers have
appeared on state television to say
they've ousted president rosh mark
christian cabori they've suspended the
constitution and they've dissolved the
government the ruling party said earlier
the president has survived an
assassination attempt gunfire erupted
early on sunday when soldiers took
control of a major military barracks in
the capital some civilian protesters
rallied to support the military
intervention
the unrest stems from frustration in the
battle against armed groups affiliated
with isil and al-qaeda soldiers have
been demanding better resources to
combat them attacks have killed around 2
000 people and forced one and a half
million from their homes
one henry wilkins is joining us on the
phone from the capital wagadugo henry
just talk us through everything that's
been happening over the last few hours
because it's been very fast moving
yeah absolutely so um all day today uh
we've been waiting for an announcement
from the likely new leaders of the uh of
the country since this morning uh the
the state broadcaster has been under
under the control
of these uh
what were mutineers as of sunday but um
uh yeah we didn't get any information
throughout the afternoon and then uh
about an hour ago reuters began to
report that the president had resigned
resigned and within minutes of that
uh military troops appeared on the
national broadcaster to announce that
the the government has been
has been dissolved we also had a
statement um in the last couple of hours
from the uh former ruling mpp party to
say that the president had
uh survived an assassination attempt uh
either earlier on on monday or on sunday
night
henry thank you very much indeed for
talking to us from wagga dugan bringing
us up to date with that situation henry
wilkins there okay we're going to speak
now to nicholas hack he's joining us
live from senegal's capital at dakar one
would imagine that this is going to have
significant ramifications for the the
whole region talk us through what you're
aware of how the
the members for example of echo wars are
reacting to all of this
make no mistake there are negotiations
taking place between west african
nations and the new uh strong man that's
in charge of burkina faso that's
that that signed the announcement made
on national tv his name is lieutenant
colonel paul
sandogo
he is now the new strong man he's in
charge
and and there are negotiations in place
the eu want to see the immediate release
of
the elected president um the af the
ecowas the african uni african union
want to see the military return to their
barracks and they want to see hawke
mcavoy or an elected
official take charge it's a very
confusing situation currently in burkina
faso despite this announcement made by
the the the the cool leaders of the
mutineers the reason being it's so
confusing is because
at stake here is the the stability of
burkina faso remember this is a place
where armed groups are active arm groups
affiliated to isil and al-qaeda rob
and that's going to be a key point isn't
it because if there is a lack of
stability and a lack of security um in
burkina faso those armed groups one
would imagine are going to be looking at
that and seeing whatever opportunities
they might be able to take in this
current situation
exactly a weak central government or a
government not by made of elected
officials
plays into the hands of armed groups
that are active in the north and then
the east of the country remember that's
what they've been trying to fight off is
a democratically elected government in
wagaduku so this situation really plays
into the hands of armed groups that are
currently active in the region it's also
comes at a time where there's been an
increased attack remember 3.5 million
people in burkina faso are in need of
urgent humanitarian assistance more than
1.5 million displaced most of them are
children these are staggering numbers
numbers that weren't like that a couple
of years ago but what you have to see in
the background of this is the
instability the political instability or
the lack of ability from uh the pr the
president or the former deposed
president in trying to deal with the
ongoing security situation now there was
the turning point in november rob when
there was an attack
on some of these troops in the in in the
region of inata where uh 50 people had
died 20 of them were soldiers soldiers
that had gone without food rations for
over two weeks that were ill-equipped
and and that caused public outcry what
rockman cowboy did was um try to
ban or censor the protest uh denouncing
the mounting insecurity instead of
focusing on the security situation of
the north what's interesting about this
new strong man lieutenant colonel
bonori
sandogo damibi he used to be and he was
promoted as a commander to
to the north of burkina faso by the
president himself he had written a book
about uh questioning
the situation between west african
armies and armed groups in the area it's
someone that's
been on the front line that has seen the
casualty
caused by the war
going on in this region of
the borders of mali burkina faso and
niger
so someone that has an element of
support from many soldiers among burkina
faso's army
rob
nick we've seen a surge in military
takeovers across places like ghana and
chad and mali and sudan the african
union echo was and the other african
nations must have been very concerned
which was next to fall and it does seem
as though burkina faso is that one
is there any indication you alluded to
it slightly in your first answer is
there anything any indication that there
is going to be more sort of
intervention or more at least talks with
as you say the new what is perceived to
be the new leadership of burkina faso or
are people just sitting back at the
moment and waiting to see what happens
next
this is a particularly difficult
situation for france the former colonial
power
it has its special forces on the ground
not far from the airport of wagaduku
under the opposite operation sabre in
fact there was a french soldier that was
wounded alongside
burkina faso's military just earlier
last week and so they have troops on the
ground in burkina faso burkina faso is
also a key ally and a key contributor to
the fight against armed groups in
neighboring mali there's a g5 sahel a
coalition of armed groups in which
burkina faso is also part so
i mean it's particularly interesting for
france
given that there are
as you mentioned
three military successive coups in the
region all of them three former french
colonies in guinea in mali and now in
burkina faso where we're seeing a step
away from democracy but for many in
burkina faso
this military takeover is seen a step
forward for security in the region mali
leading the way in many ways many
observers
in
west africa
see the steps taken by mali which is to
move away from france and closer to
other superpowers such as russia russian
mercenaries or russian fighters are
currently active in mali well they see
that as the right move forward they see
that the current status quo of engaging
with france and with key allies isn't
bringing them more safety in fact it's
making the situation worse so there
needs to be a new uh plan of action both
for the new leadership in burkina faso
but also for their key ally france in
the fight against armed groups in the
region that continues to gain ground rob
it's nicholas hack talking to us from
senegal's capital dhaka about the
announcement from burkina faso that
soldiers say they are now in charge of
the country